well it's you know I do believe you have
to have a healthy ego and there's always
I have a lot of friends who who always
and I love them and it's funny because
it's interesting they're always fine
lines and everything and I have friends
who would say yeah but look at her she
had 50 rejections from publishers and
now her book is the number one book and
now a multi-awarded movie right so and
I'm there so I'm stubborn right so why
can I be her and I have and for me it's
like well for one thing I don't know
your project enough and I don't know the
level of rejections the author God but
one thing I do believe is that I think
for every rejection depending on who
it's coming from right because you could
easily say oh she just he or she just
didn't get it right and that's possible
that's okay you move on but then if you
trust the critique if you trust that the
opinion and say wow it's from
to help for instance but it's from
somebody who's respected and who really
knows the craft whatever craft that is
then Wow take it to heart and then take
the advice whatever it is and then
revise or change your project and then
move on
more often than not maybe the next time
you submit because you took that
critique constructively and really did
the changes and that's why you got
accepted right because here you have all
this X number of rejections but how many
times have the author or the filmmaker
actually made changes to improve the
project and with all the those
improvements then that's the time it
finally so sometimes people don't know
that we all just say hey it got rejected
but now so I'll be like that but then
for every mistake you keep on repeating
it you keep on shoving the same crappy
project with no change the same annoying
whatever the same one so who in the
world would accept that even if it's a
thousand i guaranteed still a rejection
because you never improved it the minute
you improve the minute you step back and
be humble enough and look at it and be
honest and say hey this is really not
working here what's wrong and let me
correct it
then you might be on to something
you